this is actually breaking right now so
much so it's one sentence Biden quote
Putin not joking about tactical nuclear
weapons Armageddon risk at highest
levels since Cuban Missile Crisis well
hold on maybe people might need that
putt yeah yeah let's think about it
don't write that off too soon do they
have marijuana
iodine pills right they're gonna start
giving out Marinol and potassium iodide
and they're going to beg the first one
is to help keep you alive by protecting
your thyroid the second one is to chill
you out
I think that uh fear of nuclear war
benefits the military-industrial complex
so if Biden is functioning as a
mouthpiece for that or if he's just
completely an NPC just afraid of like
normal everyday stimuli that like the
more intelligent evolve people can kind
of see around and understand the basics
of I don't know the White House will
walk this back tomorrow yes he used the
word Armageddon I mean like you know you
know Peter Ducey or whoever is is going
to be in the present you know like are
we headed towards Armageddon Korean jump
here and she's gonna be like she's gonna
flip through her notebook and and then
she's going to say something that's like
well you know Armageddon that's a word
and words have meaning yes and when when
a meme is brought up people have to
wonder why because Armageddon that's an
interesting thing to say and then
they're like okay I don't I don't what
and she'll Beck I answered your question
she has the Obama kids we uh we we very
much uh does that uh a lot we believe
and and the president's been very clear
and and he's been very clear from the
beginning about what we've said about
what we believe and what we want to do
and and Armageddon you know but you're
missing the snoot when she does it
Barack Obama does the uh uh we uh but
what she does is she does that um and
she closes her eyes and looks down like
that you're so stupid
you really I'm speaking people to judge
does it too it's real Annoying like
Obama spawned a genre of politicians
that uh say ah and uh and uh talk like
this uh there's Kareem Jean-Pierre but
again I think uh
um
those are people who don't believe in it
they don't work a little bit
um and who are are abiding time in their
mind to think of the LIE that's that's
people who who need that many parts
that's what she's doing we have no
Foundation they have no beliefs that
just spill out they just absolutely all
politics and that's how you know Ben
Shapiro is the most honest person ever
yes it's just like there's no
opportunity for him to think of anything
it goes straight from the heart out of
his mouth doesn't even touch his lungs I
like very quickly and very directly and
I don't think that speaking quickly is a
marker that you're telling the truth
because we've known a lot of people who
can really spin really fast it's
actually really impressive but it's
possible that telling the truth is just
easier and it makes it quicker for you
to access those like Naturals yeah it's
nice right
I found that releasing my past secrets
on YouTube videos it was humiliating but
I've got like 100 of them where I'm just
talking about my past and my secrets and
all of a sudden I didn't they didn't pop
into my head in the middle of
conversations I didn't have to remember
or think like was I lying or was I am I
hiding something here you just kind of
flow with whatever yeah I want you to do
me a favor I want you to make me a
promise that if a nuclear strike is
imminent where we live and There Is No
Escape
I want you to stand atop the van driving
full speed holding American flag while
blasting it's the end of the world as we
know
my REM you like that song well I mean
for this scenario yeah while we hide in
the bunker with our iodine pills
no I'm saying I don't want you to die in
The Blaze of Glory unless there's no
other choice but then it would just be
the greatest endings you know to any
story oh yeah when power 108 turned into
107.9 the end they played that song for
24 hours in Ohio northeast Ohio what's
up dogs if you're from Northeast Ohio in
the 80s you remember that that night it
was the I remember uh because I'm from
Chicago q101 changed it was like a rock
station it turned to like talk radio or
something and then it just flopped
miserably so I changed it back but my
favorite thing about q101 is that I'm
sure even today I don't know I haven't
been to Chicago in a while I'm sure
they're still just playing Stone Temple
Pilots like they never stopped playing
1990s music like 92. part of this that's
the people who are listening to the
radio I mean who else is this they never
changed yeah this is this is interesting
cultural stagnation not just in that you
know because I I grew up you put on q101
in Chicago and they're playing grunge
and it was Modern and then 10 years
later it's they're still playing these
songs with some new music and then it's
20 years later and I'm just like man
they're still playing you know uh Stone
Temple Pilots and like Pearl Jam and
stuff I bet they're still they're
probably still doing it today if they
exist I don't know again I haven't been
there but then I'm just looking at a lot
of these bands
I talked about this a little bit the
other days that you're surprised they're
in their 50s they're still making new
albums yes and why is it that 311 or I
don't know if it's new well I mean it's
still touring yeah you know yeah but why
is it that back in the day at a certain
age the music stopped like you were too
old and you were just like well we're
gonna shift you know and do something
else they've become record producers
they'd work in the industry now it's
like 50 year olds still putting out
albums like what is that is it because
they don't have families well they did
like the eagles went for a long time the
Beatles now the Beatles broke up no
Stones obviously obviously stones
death will change like Zeppelin lost
their drummer um and they were like
we're done but I but I think a lot of it
is that obviously if you're like the
Beatles you never stop your Market is
working but a lot of bands fell out of
favor with the current trends but for
some reason I I think actually I think
it's simple the internet it used to be
that if the radio wouldn't play your
song anymore because it was outdated
they'd be like look people don't want to
buy this stuff anymore you're that was
it you're off the radio and now you're
retired and now you're a husband these
days it's like I got followers on
Spotify don't need to stop at all the
radio is meaningless so now it's just
you can always be big somewhere yeah we
went to hot top we were at the mall we
walked past Hot Topic on the window for
our topic is the uh Nightmare Before
Christmas right I'm like yo that movie's
30 years old 80s no it's 90 90 93 or
four or something like that I'm like
it's a 30 year old movie and young kids
are I'm like everyone in there is a
young person
I I couldn't imagine when I was a kid
walking into the mall and there was a
store that didn't pretend to be a retro
store selling everything from the 60s
yeah
well I think there's nothing you talk
about cultural stagnation there's like
nothing uh
really new coming out anymore you know
movies TV music it's all rehashes
there's nothing original arts and a huge
slump and so I feel you know people kind
of are sticking with the people who
innovated in the 90s 80s 60s there there
is actually a new show that I think is
really really good that I've been
watching Power for no yeah for uh you
know it's been about it's been a couple
months now and uh man the stories are
just compelling they're funny they make
you laugh make you cry starring and
Crossing by the way cast Castle it's a
great show I got emotional at the end
did you see yesterday's episode I I it's
touching we've integrated some powerful
music just a great scene with Chris and
I at the end me and Chris like nobody
falls off the tree as we're shooting
it's like a leaf actually fell off the
tree in the middle of the shot it was
just so natural it was so beautiful wait
you're not talking about this week's up
you're talking about this week's episode
like yesterday's episode Civil War yeah
the end of Civil War the the shot is is
stunning oh stunning cinematic
but uh yeah I highly recommend going to
timcast.com and checking out the cast
Castle series because it is new but so
so people only watch what they already
like they don't want to see anything new
so that's why the office just keeps
getting replayed over and over again so
there's no reason to do things it used
to be that there was a finite amount of
space and these networks were trying to
be fresh by making new things but now
it's it's it doesn't matter anymore look
I just watched Breaking Bad For the
First Time a couple weeks ago and now
I'm I'm about to finish Better Call Saul
which you know to be fair Better Call
Saul did just finish but these are like
old Breaking Bad was old it took me 10
years to watch it I think I watched The
Sopranos a couple months ago loved it
incredible but again just like you it's
all it's there's too much existential
stress on people to be creative these
days I think if you're stressed out it's
hard to be creative like in the 90s
people didn't care man they were doing
heroin they didn't like they were just
like rock rock and roll until they died
those dudes like well I also think too
that with streaming and with the
internet content has increased
exponentially we've never had more
volume in terms of content than we have
now but the talent pool for writing
acting you know creatives has not grown
at all so it's it's all spread out more
thin you know so you have you have a lot
more content much less quality and so
it's it's really hard to find like I
mean the office for example you there
really hasn't been a comedy that has
come out since the office that has
matched that well there was one there
was one called the office remember the
office came out and then they made
another one called the office yeah the
British one came out it's called the
office and then they immediately remade
it because it's like cultural stagnation
they couldn't even think of a new show
they just remade the office
yeah but it was still good but there was
just a remake and it could never be made
today you watch old office office
episodes you'd never see that oh man 30
Rock in in the first season Tina Fey
she's playing Liz Lemon says that she
tells her friend she voted for Obama but
she actually voted for McCain imagine a
modern SNL show where the main character
says I tell everybody I voted for
Hillary but I actually voted for Trump
twice no way they would ever allow that
that joke would not fly yeah uh the
office diversity day I haven't watched
the office but I just watched the small
clip of that that would not be okay
today yeah
for our for cast Castle but it was
brilliant hilarious some racy stuff I
think that we can we can I can't spoil
this thing but we do have
um we have a special guest coming out
next week and we're working on one of
the most uh hilariously offensive shows
we'll ever do yeah I wrote a scene for
it last night and I can't I can't say
too much but it's in line with what Luke
is talking about diversity day so it has
to do with the company and how all the
employee always have to go through
training and it'll be really really
funny dude cast Castle is legit man is
it gonna be like shockingly offensive
and a lot of people it keeps getting
better next I want to upgrade our sound
quality so it's the same room tone
everywhere so it's like the same sound
you don't hear differences and the same
lighting so once we get a Sound and
Lighting rig it's basically expanding I
think what we need to do is establish
that it's good enough to keep doing and
then once that's established we build
out I think the crew I think we need a
showrunner somebody who's got experience
having done shows like this before can
come in and be like ABCD is what you're
missing and then and then we're good to
go you know consultant or something like
that thanks for checking out this
segment from the timcast IRL podcast but
if you want to check out the full show
live tune in Monday through Friday at
8pm and if you want more special access
content head over to timcast.com and
become a member your membership helps
sustain this company keep our
journalists employed makes this show
happen and you will get access to
exclusive members only segments of the
timcast IRL podcast and there's a
massive library to check out so again go
to timcast.com or tune in Monday through
Friday at 8pm and we'll see you all
there